it's been nearly a year since the iPhone
10 was announced it is the biggest leap
board since the original iPhone which
means it's been a year of all the other
phone manufacturers trying in some way
to capture the mystique and the endless
chatter about the iPhone 10 so if that
meant shipping a new phone with a notch
or adapting a new gesture based UI
that's when phone makers have done this
year okay to be fair it's not like
everyone's waiting to see what Apple's
going to do in September and then
rushing to copy them necessarily most
phones are in production for many months
before they ship to consumers but Apple
has the uncanny ability to set the tone
for what a premium phone is going to
look like here are some examples the
knotch is the most obvious physical
attribute that started popping up on
phones this year and it was driven by
one key design choice bezel list screens
if the display takes up the whole face
of the phone there's no place to put the
camera or a 3d sensor or a speaker so
the solution is a cutout now Apple
actually wasn't first to this the
essential phone which launched last
August has a round notch at the top here
then came the iPhone 10 and then arch
became a big topic of conversation after
that huawei 1 plus LG Xiaomi all
released phones with some sort of notch
among others some people really hate the
notch
personally I don't mind it so much but
we do have Apple to thank for bringing
the notch into our smartphone vernacular
after the notch the second most
noticeable feature of this year's phones
were glass backs now Apple of course had
a glass back on the iPhone 4 and since
then Samsung's had glass backbones
but does support wireless charging Apple
rolled it out again with the iPhone 8
and iPhone 10 after which glass packs
were everywhere what's interesting is
that this trend even trickle down to
what you might consider budget phones
something like the Motorola g6 which
costs a fifth of what the iPhone 10
costs while this is given smartphones a
nice premium look it's also made them
slippery as hell
case in point but hey it's probably been
great for companies that make phone
cases or you know giant tech companies
that offer repair services like Apple
moving on unlocking your phone with your
fingerprint is so 2013 last fall Apple
raised the bar by introducing face ID
which lets you unlock your iPhone 10
with you guessed it your face now that
raised all kinds of questions ranging
from the important stuff like how secure
is face ID to the inane like can I fool
face ID with a really well-made map with
my face hi David
now Samsung had been doing face
recognition and iris scanning for a
while before and others are pushing
boundaries to Chinese phone maker vivo
shipped a phone this year that has a
fingerprint sensor built into the
display but apples face a beam has 3d
depth sensors which helps push face
scanning to the next level which brings
me to an emoji I mean really what good
would your thousand-dollar smartphone be
if you couldn't turn yourself into a
goofy unicorn or have a bunch of farm
animals sing along to Bohemian Rhapsody
right in either case the iPhone times 3d
sensors made animated emoji possible and
since no one wants to be seen as behind
the curve or slow to adapt to whatever
new tech the kids are into others
followed suit with the galaxy s 9 phone
Samsung rolled out a are emoji now these
aren't exactly the same as an emoji
Samsung's a are emoji look like you well
sort of but these also track your face
and your movements they are features in
general were a big focus around the
launch of the iPhone 10
although again Google tango came first
but showed up in phones like the zenfone
a our phone last summer
once Apple ditched the physical home
button it had to come up with a way for
people to access apps and multitask so
we have this gesture based navigation
which is a long way of saying swiping
lots of swiping but the system was
clearly appealing enough for Google to
mimic it and Android Pi its newest
mobile operating system Google replaced
the familiar lineup of three virtual
buttons at the bottom of the phone
with this single pill-shaped icon swipe
up and it shows you all of your open
apps which you can then swipe
side-to-side on since this is software
and not hardware that was predetermined
months in advance safe to say you can
really see the Apple influence here now
those are just a few examples of how
Apple set the tone for phone design from
last fall up until now but the bigger
question is what trends are we going to
see next
the short answer for now is we don't
really know Samsung did just announced
the new Galaxy Note 9 smartphones but
that looks pretty similar to last year's
Galaxy Note 8 so again we'll all be
looking to see what Apple does if Apple
goes all glass again it's already been
done if Apple makes a plus sized phone
it's been done before
if they go with a smaller phone that's
been done before - if they make the
camera better well everybody is doing
dual lens cameras and fancy portrait
modes really Apple's advantages are in
design engineering and software
unfortunately its software locks you in
but it also works well between devices
and as Hardware keeps converging more
and more the feature everyone tries to
ace might not be a hardware feature it
might be an AI feature basically how
smart a smartphone can be and that's
when we'll find out who the real
trendsetters are
[Music]